- Welcome to the Lifespan podcast,
where we discuss the science of aging
and how to be healthier
at any stage of life.
I'm David Sinclair.
I'm a professor of genetics
at Harvard Medical School
and co-director of the
Paul F. Glenn Center
for Biology of Aging Research.
I'm joined by my lovely co-author
and cohost Matthew LaPlante.
Welcome, Matt.
- I love that you called me lovely.
- I think you are lovely.
- Oh, you're nice. You're nice.
- You can be nice sometimes.
Hey, today in our episode,
we're going to be talking
about exercise and other...
what you call adversity mimetics.
But before we get to that today,
right after we stopped taping
in the last episode you went,
"Oh my God, iron!"
and then we had this really
great conversation about iron.
And so I wanted to bring us back there
before we could move forward today.
Is that all right?
- That'd be great.
So the last episode, if anybody missed it,
was about the foods that
we can eat or not eat-
- Or not eat, right.
- To live a long time.
And it was remiss of me not to bring up
a pernicious element called iron.
- [chuckles] Pernicious.
- Yeah.
It's one of the elements
that is turning out to be
quite a dangerous element
to having too much of in your body.
Increasingly we see that people
who have high levels of iron
have accelerated aging.
- Okay, yeah.
But iron is essential, right?
We all need iron.
In fact, people supplement
with iron a lot of times.
- Right.
Well, we need iron.
It's a major component of hemoglobin,
which carries oxygen which we need.
But the levels don't need to
be as high as we once thought.
In fact, people who live a long time
and have these diets that are recommended,
I typically say they
have lower levels of iron
and lower levels of hemoglobin.
And this is not necessarily a bad thing.
Conversely, people who
have very high levels,
either genetically, hemochromatosis,
or take a supplement and end
up with high levels of iron,
might be predisposing
themselves to accelerated aging.
- Okay, so what about just...
I mean, this plays into your idea
about why people should limit
their meat intake though;
because meat intake, meat is high in iron,
especially red meats,
especially are higher in iron.
- That's one aspect.
But typically if people
are taking multivitamin
with high levels of iron,
this could be a really bad thing.
It'll accumulate in tissues.
And we know now that
particularly ferrous iron
leads to the production of free radicals
that damage tissues in
the body and, even worse,
it leads to the accumulation
of these zombie cells
which we call senescent cells,
and those drive the aging process,
in part, large part,
because they leach these
inflammatory molecules
that cause other cells in the vicinity
to become inflamed, to age,
to senesce and even cause cancer.
- Let's back up for a second here,
because I think we're going to talk more
about senescent cells in a coming episode.
But we have mentioned
free radicals before,
and I think that's a word
that gets thrown around a lot.
And maybe not everybody
understands free radicals.
- Right.
And we're not just talking about
people in Portland, Oregon.
- Or Eugene, or Berkeley.
- Yeah.
So these are free radicals that...
These have been around for
millions of years, of course,
and we've known about them
for at least the last 70.
There are three main
types of free radicals.
There's the superoxide molecule,
which is quite damaging
and can lead to what are called
advanced glycation end products
which are basically
proteins that are damaged.
It's one of the reasons you want to fast
sometimes during the day
to get rid of these damaged proteins.
There's a superoxide anion, it's called,
which creates most of the
oxidative stress in the body.
And then there's a third
one, hydrogen peroxide,
which you can buy a bottle
of and dye your hair blonde
or orange as my hair
went during the pandemic.
Those three things are
really bad for cells.
- You dyed your hair during the pandemic?
- I got bored.
I just dyed it.
- How did it look?
- Horrible.
It really went orange.
I've been dyeing it ever
since just to cover it up.
But it's almost gone, thank goodness.
But this is where iron comes in:
When you have a superoxide molecule,
it'll be turned into peroxide
by an enzyme called superoxide dismutase,
which is extremely important
to get rid of that superoxide
which is going to damage the cell.
But then you get hydrogen peroxide
and we know how bad that is.
Look at my hair.
You don't want that circulating.
So then what happens
is there's a molecule called glutathione
which will turn that into water.
But if you have too much iron around,
there won't be enough
chance to detoxify it
and it'll be turned into
this hydroxyl radical.
And that's a really damaging molecule
that goes on to damage your DNA, your RNA,
lipids, proteins, and
drive aging and senescence.
So you want to have iron;
enough not to be lethargic,
to have enough oxygen transported,
but not super high levels
that'll cause accelerated aging.
- And this is going to be
different for different people.
10% of the population in the United States
has the a HFE gene,
which makes them more
susceptible to hemochromatosis,
which means they have to
be even more concerned.
You can't know this without knowing
if you carry this gene though, right?
I mean-
- Right.
You do need to measure things.
And that's why I, myself,
and I recommend people measure
their blood bio chemistry
and determine whether their iron,
whether it's free iron,
which is the worst type,
or even the bound iron are out of whack.
And you can correct for that.
In the case of a normal person,
I would say don't take her an
iron supplement necessarily,
although women may need it
certain times of the month.
But people who have hemochromatosis,
they're particularly susceptible to aging.
And the recommendation, typically,
of a doctor is donate blood if you can.
- Okay.
So just to go over what
we talked about last time
really quickly.
You advocate for a plant-based diet.
You advocate for low iron levels.
What am I missing?
- Well, we're going to
talk about that today.
What type of exercise works best.
- Oh, I was just talking
about how we should eat,
but yeah.
[Matt and David laugh]
- Well, eat less often.
- Eat less often?
- Yeah.
So I've gone from not eating breakfast
now to not eating lunch as well,
and just focus on dinner;
and giving my body a
rest from food overnight
and through the middle of the day
so that it turns on our
defensive genes against aging,
those three buckets:
the mTOR, which senses
amino acids or lack thereof;
the AMPK, which senses energy,
which is glucose mainly;
and the sirtuins, which I work on,
that sense all of those
things, including exercise.
And those three protective mechanisms,
we can turn on by eating the right things,
eating less often and exercising.
- And this leads in really well, actually,
to what we're talking about today,
because what we're talking about
is bringing your body into a
state of perceived adversity
as a way to turn on these genes.
Before we can do that,
we've got some business to take care of.
- We do.
Because this podcast comes
to everybody for free,
we should definitely mention the sponsors
that make that possible.
Our first sponsor is Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens is a greens powder
developed from a complex
blend of 75 vitamins,
minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients.
It's filled with adaptogens for recovery,
probiotics and digestive
enzymes for gut health.
They also have vitamin C and zinc citrate
for immune support.
I've been drinking Athletic Greens
for a number of years now.
I do that not just because it tastes good,
but because I travel and I
often don't eat perfectly.
And by having it every morning,
I rest assured that I'm
getting all of the vitamins
and minerals that I
need for optimal health.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim a special offer.
They're giving five free travel packs
plus a year supply of vitamin
D3 for immune support;
and K2, which will keep the
calcium out of your arteries
and put it into your bones.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim this special offer.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is an app that syncs
with a continuous glucose
monitor, or a CGM,
which they provide,
and that interprets your
glucose data for you.
I've been so impressed with Levels
that I've recently joined
them as an advisor.
Monitoring your blood glucose levels
allows you to run experiments
to see how different foods impact you.
I did this myself a number of years ago,
and I continue to do it.
I've learned a lot
about what kind of foods
I should avoid and which
ones are okay to eat.
If you'd like to try Levels,
you can skip the 150,000
person list and join today
by going to levels.link/sinclair,
that's levels.link/sinclair.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from
your blood and your DNA
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals.
I've using InsideTracker
for over a decade.
Over that time,
I've been able to optimize my health
and even potentially get
younger than my actual age.
They make it really easy.
You can have somebody come
to your house, like I have,
or you can go to a local lab.
The data is easily uploaded by them,
and you can see a dashboard on your body
that also gives you
personalized recommendations
for exercise and nutrition.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can visit insidetracker.com/sinclair
and you'll get 25% of
any InsideTracker plan.
Use the code Sinclair, my
last name, at the checkout.
- All right, so let's get into this.
In this episode,
we're talking about some of the things
that people can do to create
and mimic in their lives
the biological adversity
that's more conducive
to better lifespans and
health spans that we call-
- We call these adversity mimetics.
- We call these that.
I mean, when you say we call these that,
is it like you and I call them that?
'Cause I know we call them
that, but is it like...
Is that a term that scientists use,
that people actually use right now?
- No, we just made it up.
- You're just making it up.
But it's a good word, right?
- We'll use it, trademark.
- And the reason why
adversity is important
ties back to this idea
that you've proposed
of a survival circuit.
So before we move forward into this,
let's talk about the survival circuit.
We don't have to go way,
way back in history.
- Not 4 Billion years,
we'll come forward in time a little bit?
- Yeah, you can go back 4 billion years,
and that's in the book.
But we're going to start in the 1990s
with Cynthia Kenyon and
her work on sea aliens.
- That's a good starting point.
So in the 1980s,
it was all about just free radicals.
We didn't know that aging
could actually be controlled
by any genes,
it was certainly not single genes.
And Cynthia came along as
a young graduate student
and looked for worms
that would live longer.
And she mutated them and
found a strain of worm,
a mutant worm,
that was living twice as long;
so instead of living for 15 days, 30 days.
And that was a remarkable finding
because when she dissected
the worms, bred them out,
found that it was due to
a single gene mutation.
And when she cloned the gene
and found out where it was,
it was in a gene that sensed insulin,
it's the insulin receptor
gene called DAF-2.
That was remarkable
because it had nothing
to do with free radicals,
it had nothing to do with DNA damage,
it was a signaling molecule.
And that was the start of a revolution
in understanding how to control aging
by using genes and supplements and drugs
that turn on the body's defenses.
- And this was the first
so-called longevity gene?
- Yeah, I would say that was the first.
It came very close to the work
that we were doing at MIT.
We were maybe a year
later than her, but we-
- You seem a little annoyed by that.
- Nope, it's not much me.
I'm careful because my
supervisor Lenny Guarente
used to get really annoyed
when he was told that
he was slightly behind.
He thought his work was
being done at the same time.
So those two used to be the...
I guess maybe still are at
the forefront of this field;
they're certainly the
grandparents, if nothing else.
And they both showed...
So Cynthia in worms and
then Lenny in yeast,
where I was at MIT,
made the finding that a
single gene alteration
can have a huge impact on
an organism's lifespan.
- And these genes,
there's a few of them now
that we've identified.
And all of them seem to work
on a very similar circuit
that all starts with adversity.
- That's right.
These signaling proteins,
like the DAF-2 one that Cynthia discovered
and the sirtuins that we work on,
we didn't know what they
were doing at first.
It was like, "This is crazy.
It's got nothing to do with
DNA repair and free radicals."
But then when we tracked what
they were actually doing,
it turns out they're speaking
to the rest of the cell
to keep the cell healthy and alive.
So in the case of that worm,
those worms weren't just longer lived,
the program to survive was activated.
Those worms are stress resistant.
You can hit them with heat,
you can hit them with cold,
you can starve them or just
put them in happy conditions,
they live longer.
The paradigm is that
normally a worm responds
to its what's in the environment;
if it's starved, it'll
hunker down, it'll survive.
But here we had a worm that
was mimicking starvation
and was able to have the benefits
without having to starve itself.
- How do the genes, for
lack of a better word, know?
How do they know that the
conditions are adverse
and they need to turn on?
- Well, there are various sensors.
And so that the three main
pathways that control this:
we've talked about mTOR,
which is sensing the levels
of amino acids in the cell.
Lower levels of certain amino acids,
branch chain amino acids,
are good for the cell
because they downregulate mTOR activity.
That's one way.
The AMPK senses energy, glucose;
and then the sirtuin sense NAD,
which is a molecule that goes up
with exercise and hunger.
Together, those are the sensors.
Now, how does a cell
communicate with other cells?
Well, there's insulin.
Like we know when we eat a meal,
insulin goes from our
pancreas into our bloodstream
and tells the rest of the body,
"Hey, you got sugar already,
suck it in, use it."
That's a signaling protein.
And what Cynthia's worms ended
up when they were mutated
is that that signal to bring
in the glucose was mutated
and this insulin signal was absent.
And when don't have the
insulin signaling in your worm,
it means you're hungry
and you get the benefits of being hungry
without having to starve.
- So our body is this always
active monitoring system.
We're perceiving the world around us
and the world around us
is constantly throwing
different stressors at us,
or at least it was in
human history, right?
We've always been a little
cold or a little hungry,
or a little scared,
or having to run from
this animal or that animal
that wanted to eat us.
This is the environment
that our species evolved in,
that all species evolved in, right,
is this constant state of adversity.
- Right.
And that adversity, we've
evolved to fight back.
And so in the past,
our bodies were constantly
fighting disease
and deterioration throughout life.
Even before birth, we're
fighting against entropy,
things are falling apart.
The aging clock that we can now measure
begins at conception.
But if you fast forward to now,
our society is built on comfort.
We've got...
Most countries have
enough food and shelter.
We can sit down,
we don't have to run away
from predators very often.
And this is a real problem
because these longevity defenses
that normally would be activated
by being cold and hungry
and running are lethargic.
The body doesn't expend
energy to defend itself
unless there's a need for it.
And modern society is the worst thing.
- We've taken away those needs.
Yeah, we love comfort, it feels good,
but that's the worst thing
for long-term health.
We need to trick the body
into getting out of its comfort zone
by doing these things we've talked about:
eating the right foods,
including foods that are stressed;
eating less often-
- Which puts stress on us,
which causes our body to feel like
it needs to protect itself.
Because if we're not filling it
with all of the nutrients
and calories we want,
it perceives a need,
it proceeds adversity and
it turns on these genes.
- Right.
And as long as we have adequate nutrition.
That's what we call intermittent fasting
with adequate nutrition or IFAN,
this is another term we
just coined in this podcast,
that allows the body to
turn on these defenses
without suffering long-term
negative consequences.
What's interesting, I find,
is that even though we know the fridge
is probably full with food,
our bodies are not that smart,
our bodies don't get that message.
And we can trick it,
trick the body into thinking,
"Oh my goodness,
the fridge is running out of food,
or the field or the
forest is lacking in food,
we better get to hunker down and survive."
What are those things?
You burn fat, you
increase your metabolism,
so you've got more energy
to run around and find food.
You become more alert
because you've got to go find more food.
And you defend your body against insults,
whether it's incoming infections
or diseases from within.
And that's cool that we
can trick our bodies.
And it's not that hard,
we just need to do the
things we're talking about
on this podcast.
- And when we're talking...
We've already talked about the real,
key effects that come
from eating less often
to basically turn on this
adversity mimetic effect.
There's another really
easy way to do this though.
- Right, and that's get off your butt.
- Just get off your butt.
- Yeah, It's not that hard,
as we say sitting here doing this podcast.
But one way I do it is
I have a standing desk.
so my butt actually atrophied.
When we were writing this book "Lifespan,"
I ended up with a cramp
in my piriformis muscle,
which is the one that-
- Wait, in your what?
- Yeah, yeah, it's a small muscle.
- Where is it?
- Size doesn't matter.
It's right in your hip,
it goes through that hole in your pelvis,
and it's essential for standing,
and it was cramped up-
- I always wondered
what that hole was four.
- Yeah, it's-
- There's a muscle that goes through it?
- Yes.
- [Matthew] Okay.
- All right?
But it was cramped up
on my left-hand side.
So I was limping for about nine months
after we wrote the book, and I thought,
"Great, I'm writing about
health and longevity
and now I've crippled myself."
I eventually got it to go away
with a combination of exercise,
physio and an injection of NAD in my butt,
which we'll get to in
probably the next episode.
But the point here is that
sitting down is bad for us.
You atrophy,
you have less muscle which
means your hormone levels,
particularly testosterone,
will go down;
and you become in pain,
that's not a good thing.
But ultimately if you
have not a lot of muscle
in your hips, particularly,
you can break your
bones when you fall over
when you're older.
And all of that means you
need to get off your butt,
stand up;
even better, go for a walk; even better,
go for a run or cycle
to get what we call a hypoxic state going.
Your body needs to suck in more oxygen.
And that has remarkable health benefits.
- And we really have to work hard at this.
'Cause, I mean,
you're saying this as we're
sitting in these chairs, right?
A couple of days after I sat
down in a chair for a long time
in an airplane to get here, right?
We've got a nice comfy couch over there
that we've been working on.
Like, we actually have to
actively pursue opportunities
to do this, to get exercise,
to promote this adversity mimetic effect
because our lives are built
around comfort and sedentariness?
- Yes, that's true.
And what I think most
people don't appreciate
is that exercise isn't just beneficial
for your fitness and for your vitality,
it actually can stop
diseases in their tracks.
Exercise can slow down cancer.
In fact, it can prevent
up to 23% of all cancers
from occurring.
That's true for cardiovascular disease.
In fact, it has an even
bigger effect on that,
30% reduction just by doing
moderate exercise every week.
50 minutes is sufficient,
or three times a week with 10 minutes.
All-cause mortality, right?
So what we are...
All-cause mortality is
basically slowing down aging,
that's a 27% reduction
in the rate of aging
just by exercising.
- The thing you just said...
I love this idea of connecting the idea
of all-cause mortality with aging;
because as we've presented here,
as you've been arguing
for quite some time,
most diseases which bring us
toward the end of our lives
are really just an accumulation
of the symptoms of aging.
And so if you bring down the disease rate
across various diseases,
which is bringing down
all-cause mortality,
you're really just...
It's just another way of saying
we're bringing down aging.
- We must be. Exactly.
And we can also now measure
that with the biological clock,
the so-called Horvath clock,
named after my good friend Steve Horvath.
That is now a measure of the process
that leads to all of these
diseases that kill us.
And one way that we know for a fact
to slow down the ticking
of that biological clock
is exercise.
- Any any kind of exercise is good.
This is why the 10,000
steps a day goal is popular;
generally speaking, it's good.
It's not a magic number.
I think somebody came up with 10,000,
and actually some studies
have shown health benefits
that are...
exist at 4 to 6,000, kind
of peter out from there.
But the basic idea here
is that when we move we burn calories,
we're putting our bodies
into at least a low state of adversity.
- Right. So try to get 4,000.
And 10,000 seems to be even better.
- It's a great goal.
It's a round number.
It's fine, right?
- Just get off your ass,
that's what we're saying,
that's all it takes.
It's not that hard.
Walk around the block a few times.
And particularly after a meal,
as we spoke about last time;
walking after a meal
gets your glucose levels
to be more level, which is what you want.
- Which relates to this...
We were talking about this
old Chinese proverb, like,
99 steps after a meal...
No, a thousand steps after
a meal, you'll live to 99.
But walk after you eat.
- Right
- Because?
- Well, it'll stimulate
the uptake of glucose,
but also it'll get your muscles moving
and stimulate the production
of new blood vessels,
make sure that you don't run
out of oxygen later in life.
But mostly what happens when you move,
the first thing that happens
is a really important reaction
that involves one of
these longevity pathways,
the middle one that I
refer to, called AMPK.
- And we can turn on AMPK just
with a low level of exercise,
just start that adversity?
- Yeah, so AMPK registers
energy in the cell,
which is chemical energy called ATP.
And when you have low levels of ATP,
AMPK gets activated;
and it stands for AMP activated kinase.
And AMP is what you get a lot of
when you don't have
enough of this fuel, ATP.
Long story short:
When you have high
levels of AMPK activity,
you will make more mitochondria
which gives you long lasting benefits.
So after you've exercised,
your body will be making more power,
more of these organelles, we call them,
that will actually give you
long-term health benefits
beyond the period of exercise.
- We know that low level
exercise alone is good,
it's a good start.
We also know that it's really not enough.
You need to also be getting
a pretty consistent dose
of vigorous exercise too.
It doesn't have to be a lot.
A lot of these studies
show 10 minutes a day,
15 minutes a day,
even even 15 minutes a week
if you're getting started
is going to have health benefits.
But vigorous exercise,
the easiest way to think about it
is you your breathing rate goes up
and your heart rate goes up, right?
- Right.
And there's a reason why vigorous exercise
is so important beyond
just walking and standing,
it's that you have hypoxia.
Low levels of oxygen are
undoubtedly good for you,
even though they may not feel good.
And you know you're hypoxic
when you're panting so much
you cannot carry out a conversation.
That's what you're aiming for
for at least 10 minutes
a few times a week.
So why is being out of breath important?
Very rarely people ask that.
Well, the main reason-
- 'Cause it doesn't seem
to make sense, honestly.
Like, you need oxygen.
- Right.
So, again, it's this hormesis idea.
A little bit of what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger.
So what's happening is
when you're hypoxic,
is you're turning on a
what's called HIF-1alpha.
hypoxia inducible factor,
and that pathway turns on a
bunch of really helpful genes
that control new blood vessel
growth and mitochondria.
My good friend and
colleague over at Harvard
won the Nobel prize in 2019
for discovering HIF-1alpha
and its role in biology.
Now, the other thing that happens in that;
there's two things.
So one is they HIF-1alpha that
turns on a generic program,
that's good.
But what also happens is you
get free radicals generated.
Because when you don't have enough oxygen,
those electrons that that
should normally be used
by what's called the
electron transport chain
in mitochondria, which generates ATP,
they fly out and they become
a super oxide radical.
- Can we talk about the electrons?
'Cause it's really fascinating
how this thing works.
I mean, it's like it is
a little circuit around-
- Yeah, it's a little
battery made of proteins.
And there's a string of proteins
that come together in the membrane
and they pass along an electron,
like a hot potato.
They don't want to hold onto
it, they shove it along:
Get rid of it, get rid of it.
And in doing so, they're pumping protons,
which are hydrogen atoms,
into the inner membrane space.
'Cause there's two membranes
that surround the mitochondria.
And in that little space,
the goal is to make it really acidic
by putting in these protons into there,
and this electron
transport chain does that.
But you need oxygen because at the end,
when you get to the end,
you got to get rid of this electron
and they give it to oxygen, okay?
And then that's called respirations.
That's why we need to
breathe so hard when we run
and why we need oxygen in the first place.
Now, if you don't have enough oxygen,
then that'll lead to these
free radicals being produced
and it'll damage the cell.
So you might say, "Well,
that makes no sense.
If you're running and
you're damaging the cell,
it's going to be bad, right?"
But remember, a little
bit of damage can be good.
So what happens is it stimulates
what's called mitohormesis,
mitochondrial hormesis.
And that has a whole
variety benefits as well,
including the manufacture
of more mitochondria
that gives you energy.
But I want to mention something
that's really interesting, I think,
about this electron transport chain.
Remember how I said those protons,
those hydrogens get pumped
into that little space
to make it acidic?
So now you've got what's
called a gradient.
You've got more of them in that space
than inside the mitochondria
in the inner bubble.
They want to get out;
if they got too much somewhere,
they should equilibrate.
And what the cell does
is it puts little holes
that protons can escape
through, a little...
It's it's called the ATPase.
And what happens is as
those protons shoot through,
it's like a hydroelectric dam turbine.
And as they shoot through,
it literally spins like a turbine.
There's a little wheel at
the bottom of this tube
that spins super fast
many times per second,
and that spinning allows it
to make ATP or chemical energy
which then you use then to
burn to make the muscle work.
And so what's really interesting
is that the more mitochondria you have,
if you've been exercising for a few weeks,
allows you to make more chemical energy,
and you don't feel puffed
as much as you did before.
And the other thing that's happened
besides having more mitochondria
is that you've built more
blood vessels in your body,
and so your oxygen gets
transported to the tissues.
Now, both of those things
go awry as we get older.
And we'll talk later and tomorrow
about how you can circumvent that
and reverse your age to be
able to regain that ability.
- With drugs, and
molecules, and supplements?
- Besides what we're talking
about today, exercise itself.
- Yeah.
We keep going back to this idea
of a little bit of
adversity is good for you.
Like, a lot of anything's
going to kill you,
but a little bit of a lot of these things
that might in big doses kill
you is really good for us
'cause it puts our bodies
into the state of adversity.
Let's talk about this
in terms of another effect of exercise,
increased glucose sensitivity.
- Right.
So as you get older,
our muscles and our brain
become less sensitive
to the insulin.
The pancreas is putting out
increasingly more and more
trying to cope with this
insensitivity that happens.
Now, that's largely,
we think now because of
this aging biological clock,
that the genes that are required
for muscle cell to function
or brain cell to function
are getting switched on
and off in the wrong way.
We call this ex-differentiation.
And if you didn't see episode 1,
you might want to go back
and hear more about that.
Basically cells are losing
their identity as they get older
and not putting out a
particular protein called GLUT4,
which is a glucose transporter,
on the outside of the cells.
So the muscles are not
bringing in the glucose.
That's two problems, right?
First of all,
you don't have your energy
to burn in the mitochondria
to make energy.
The other problem is that that sugar,
that glucose that circulates
in your bloodstream
and doesn't get taken up into
your muscle and your brain
starts to damage the lining
of the blood vessels,
and we know that is type 2 diabetes
and cardiovascular disease.
- And that's where VEGF comes in?
- So VEGF is a little protein
that signals the formation
of new blood vessels.
When you exercise-
- How do you spell this VEGF, by the way?
- V-E-G-F.
- Okay, so if people want to look this up.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Okay. All right.
So VEGF?
- So VEGF is made by
muscles after you exercise;
if you've gone for your
run or even your walk,
but running is even better.
And there's a gene called PGC-1alpha,
that is what's called
a transcription factor.
It'll be made,
it'll bind to the upstream
side of the VEGF gene
and make more of this VEGF protein.
Now, VEGF will be secreted
out of the muscle and diffuse
or just leak out into the
lining of blood vessels.
Now, the lining of the blood
vessels is made of cells
called endothelial cells
which pick up the signal,
they have little
receptors that sense VEGF.
And when they get that signal that says,
"Oh wow, we're being chased
by a saber tooth tiger
for the last week,
we better build more blood vessels,"
and they do that.
Normally, if you have a
tube which is a capillary,
almost microscopic blood vessels,
what happens is the endothelial cells
will start to branch out to the side
and make a new blood vessel.
And that's what you get with exercise.
Conversely, if you sit around all day,
you won't build new blood vessels,
you'll actually have fewer and fewer
and your muscle and your brain
starts to get starved of oxygen.
Now, one of the big problems
we discovered is during aging,
that signaling pathway,
that signaling mechanism is defective.
And even though you're
exercising as you get older,
you're not getting the benefits of it;
you don't get the new blood vessels.
- And you can see this in a mouse.
I mean, when you pull the mouse apart,
not to be too graphic,
but you can actually see
these thinning vessels.
- We don't even need
to hurt the mouse to see this.
We can use imaging to see
the blood flow in a mouse
without hurting it,
and we can see the bright red areas
where the blood's flowing nicely.
And in an old mouse, you don't
get that even with exercise.
But we found a way to restore
the youth of the muscle
and restore the ability of that VEGF
to trigger new blood vessel formation.
And the trick was to turn
on the production of NAD,
which is the fuel for the
sirtuin survival circuit.
- Which can be turned on by exercise
because exercise upregulates NAMPT.
- Yeah, also known as NAMPT.
- NAMPT.
- Some people call it that.
But, yeah,
this is the relative of
that ancient yeast gene
that we talked about in a first episode
that extends lifespan of yeast cells.
- So let's add one more piece to this,
and that is how exercise
impacts the epigenome.
- Yeah, the epigenome...
If you missed episode 1,
I encourage you to go listen
to that and watch that
because we covered what the epigenome is
and how it affects the aging process.
But the summary is that the epigenome
is the regulator of the DNA.
It tells the genes whether
it'd be on and off.
And that goes wrong during aging,
and may actually be the reason we age.
And one of the reasons we believe that
is that you can measure
biological age now in people.
I could take one of your cells, Matt,
back to my lab.
Well, actually I have to
take a chunk of your cells
or cheek swab,
and we can measure the rate of your aging.
It's called the Horvath clock
or DNA methylation clock.
And when you look at people
that have lived a healthy lifestyle,
say they've been exercising
for the last 30 years.
they are much younger epigenetically,
according to this clock,
than somebody who hasn't.
So that tells us that
very likely that exercise
is not just protecting you
against cardiovascular disease,
it's slowing down your
overall rate of aging.
- There are other clocks as well.
One of our-
- There are many actually.
- So one of our researchers, Dave Johnson,
was involved in a study that
used the proteomic clock,
which works similarly.
Let's talk about that really quick.
'Cause it's another way to
measure biological aging.
- Right.
So you can measure a
proteins in the blood,
which change predictably over time.
There's a protein called
GDF15, which is circulating...
It's now a really great
biomarker for aging.
In fact,
GDF15 is one of those genes
that was used in that study
we referred to last episode,
where the Mediterranean diet
slowed the aging process.
They found that GDF15,
the methylation on that clock
marker was also slowed down.
The point here being that
these proteomic clocks
and the epigenetic clocks,
and some others like an immuno clock,
can be used now to understand
what slows down aging
but, importantly,
how do you reverse it
with various treatments?
And we've gone from a
field where we had no idea
what was going on in aging;
really, we had to look at
tens of thousands of people
on metformin to see if it helped health
to a point where we can
take a hundred people,
treat them with something;
two months later, see if
they've gotten younger or not.
And those experiments
are being done right now.
- And one of the things
we could treat them with
is exercise.
Exercise, in the study we
were just talking about,
they looked at aerobically active people
versus sedentary people,
and the aerobically active people
were five and a half
years younger on average,
according to this
proteomic biological clock.
Presumably we'd see the same thing
if we used a Horvath
clock or an immuno clock.
- Yeah. And that's true, actually.
It's been done on exercised people
and they are also epigenetically young.
And what's important about
this clock, to realize,
is that it doesn't just tell
you your biological age.
You can actually predict
when you're going to die
or when someone's going to die.
And when I say that some people
probably got uncomfortable.
- It's a little morbid.
- "I don't want to know this."
Well, consider this,
that 80% of your future
health is in your own hands,
it's modifiable;
20% is genetic, which you
can't do much about yet.
That's powerful.
If you have the tools to
change your rate of aging...
First of all,
you have to measure it
to know if it's working.
So I recommend that,
and we'll talk about ways
to do that practically.
But once you have that
number, then work with me.
We can tell you here in podcast
how to actually slow and
reverse that process.
- Well, we use car
analogies a lot, you and I.
I think a lot of people do these.
But it bears mentioning, like,
you know that your car's
not going to last forever.
There's a shelf life for any car.
You get to choose based on how
you treat the car over time
whether or not the car
is going to last 100,000
miles or 200,000 miles
or 3 or 400,000 miles.
- Right, take it to the body shop repair
and the mechanics more often.
That's what we're talking
about for our bodies.
Don't just let things fall apart.
- And that's why knowing is important.
- Well, you need to measure it?
You need to know when
the car needs a service.
You need to know, if
you're tweaking that knob,
whether you're doing harm or good.
- And to that end,
one of the really cool
and exciting developments
that's happening right now
is there's this sort of
race for these clocks
to become available
widely for people to use,
so much so that the price point
is predicted to be, what, like buck?
- Well, it's coming down the whole time.
- For a Horvath test?
- Right.
So right now if you want to
check your biological age,
you can go to InsideTracker,
one of our kind sponsors,
that's a blood test;
or you can also have a DNA test,
which is available by
for a few hundred dollars
from various vendors.
A student in my lab, Patrick Griffin,
we've posted recently a paper,
which can be accessed on bioarchive.org,
that describes a way
to pool, put together,
thousands of people's samples
and run them all together,
bringing the cost of that test
down to less than a dollar,
which means that very
shortly in the future
when we bring out this product,
and we are bringing it out soon,
you should be able to
do this test routinely
and see whether you try
new diet or a supplement
or just meditation,
whether you're actually
benefiting from that.
- A lot of people hear
all of this and they go,
"Okay, I get it, I have to exercise, but,"
and I hear this a lot,
"but I hate to run."
Like, everybody thinks
that that's the only thing
they're allowed to do.
And I think physicians may
contribute to this a little bit
by saying, like,
"Okay, well, I need to get
you running and jogging,"
and whatever.
It's not just running, right?
Like, what's the best kind of exercise?
- Well, there isn't one-
- It's the exercise you're going to do.
- It's what you love doing.
And it can be a sport.
It could be wind surfing,
it could be sailing;
but just move, that's the main thing.
There's even sex, which is...
We actually looked this up.
It's not as good as we thought.
- We did look this up.
We were really hopeful
when we looked this up,
but it burns like four
calories a minute or something.
It's not as good as-
- Well, I'm sure it depends
on the individual, right?
- I mean, you can make sex more aerobic.
You can make it part of
your exercise regimen,
but you have to have a partner;
a consenting, willing partner;
who also wants to make it part
of their exercise regimen.
- It's only 4.2 calories
per minute, which...
And we also looked up the
average length of sex,
and it's about five minutes.
So that's not a lot.
- So you wold have burned 20 calories
if you're an average person.
I'll burn 10.
- So Instead of that,
you probably need to go for
a longer walk afterwards
to really burn off those calories
and get your blood flowing.
- And however you get your exercise,
be it running or sailing,
apparently, or sex,
both the World Health Organization
and the Mayo clinic
recommend at least 75 minutes
of vigorous exercise a week,
so that's 15 minutes a day, 10 minutes-
- And it's better if you
spread it out over the week.
- Right, yeah, don't do it all at once.
But that's the starting point.
And most people can do that.
You can be the busiest
person in the world,
you can be the most unhealthy
you can get your heart
rate and your breathing up
for 10 minutes a day.
- Sure, you can.
And the benefits will be huge.
You'll feel better,
you'll look better,
and you will also have a
better resting heart rate.
That's one of the best
measures of your fitness.
If you're less than 50
for a resting heart rate,
that's really good.
For someone my age, in my 50s,
mine's usually around mid-40s.
That's a good indication
of how well you're doing.
And if you've got a high heart rate,
it's you're either too
stressed or you're unfit,
try to bring that down again.
You can measure your
heart rate pretty easily,
just put your hand on your arm.
But you could also either wear
a ring or a new fitness...
these fitness apps-
- There's all kind of wearables now
that are going to help you do this.
- Yeah, and I'm a big proponent
of measuring things, right?
'Cause otherwise you're flying blind.
So I wear a ring, I wear a wrist watch.
I sometimes wear-
- You're wearing right now.
- I am.
This also measures sleep,
which we'll get to in another episode.
There are some advanced bio monitors
we're also going to cover.
There's one that I stick
on my chest for two weeks
that measures my body a
thousand times a second
for various parameters,
including my heart function.
And in the future,
these will be used by people
to predict heart attacks
as well as the flu,
and all sorts of issues like depression.
In the future, we're not
going to be flying blind,
we're going to be monitored
a thousand times a second,
as opposed to now where you
go to the doctor once a year
and they spend 15 minutes
asking you, "How do you feel?"
which is a joke.
- Right, right.
Because in addition to the fact
that it's a single
assessment at a single time,
it's highly subjective,
it's self-reported.
This is just crap data.
- Yeah.
This has a bit of an side,
but it's worth noting here
that I've been measuring
myself for over 10 years
using InsideTracker.
And that data is wonderful.
It's graphed and you can
see when things go wrong,
I've corrected it.
They do an inner age study.
There's a measure called Inner Age 2.0
which tells you how you're doing
compared to others your age,
and you try to keep that low.
And based on that calculation,
I've been getting younger
for the last 10 years,
which is great to talk about
but it also means that I'm
optimizing my body every time
when I do something;
and if something doesn't
work, then I won't do.
- And we are going to get into this,
but I do want to...
I've got a friend, Nate Price,
who helps people do this
at the Institute for Systems Biology,
and they help people create these charts
so that they could then bring
in to show their doctors.
And he was telling me about this woman
who brought her chart into the doctor.
And the doctor was at first
dismissive and she said,
"Well, won't you at least look at it?"
And the doctor looked at it and went,
"Oh wow, this is really helpful."
- That's exactly the
response of my doctor too.
My doctor said, "Well, how do you feel?"
and I said, "I'm good, I'm sleeping well."
And he said, "Okay, see you next time."
I said, "No, hang on.
Let's do some more.
I've got some data, can I show you?"
And I showed him the
InsideTracker data on Zoom
and he said, "This is wonderful.
I wish all my patients had this data."
Of course, he cannot order
43 biomarkers every time.
The health insurance won't pay for it.
But individuals,
if they want to spend their money;
instead of coffee, they can
put it into a blood test.
Doctors actually do respect those data
because they're actually
produced by the same companies
that the doctors would use anyway.
- And to bring this all back...
To tie this all back to exercise
and these other adversity mimetics,
which we're going to get
to, having this data...
I'm a big soccer fan.
The first time I saw a soccer
player take off his shirt,
he was wearing a bra and I thought,
"What the heck is going on?"
but it's actually holding these trackers
that are measuring things
in the middle of games,
in the middle of practices.
The world's best athletes
are doing this right now
and it's becoming more and more available
for other people to track as well.
And once you have this data,
you can start to act on this data.
You can start to arrange
your exercise routine
so that you're getting the most out of it.
- Exactly. And they can be fun too.
You can use GPS to see where you're going.
You can compare it with your
colleagues, your friends:
"I'm running more than you."
- Let's move along here
because we've got a
lot more to talk about.
But before we get away from exercise
and start talking about these
other adversity mimetics,
there's another form of
exercise that I know you enjoy,
that I enjoy, that a lot of people enjoy,
but maybe doesn't get as much attention
as aerobic exercises,
is weight training.
- I'm glad you said that.
All right, so weight training.
Yeah, I do that fairly often;
I would say at least every
other day, if not every day.
The way I do that is I
have a gym in my bedroom
and I also have weights next to my desk.
- You also have them in the
trunk of your car right now
I saw.
- I do.
It's 'cause I travel a lot,
and so I'm taking weights with me.
But the reason that I do weightlifting
is that it's going to
maintain my hormone levels,
it's going to maintain
my ability to walk well
and stay upright and have good posture.
It makes me look better,
although you may say that's debatable.
But also, as I get older-
- It's not debatable.
You're really good looking guy, David.
- Thanks.
You're lovely, Matthew.
- [Matthew] Thank you.
- The other thing that
is often not appreciated
is it's harder to build
muscle as you get older,
and you want to maintain that muscle mass.
I'm losing about 1% of
my muscle mass every year
unless I maintain it or build it up.
As you get older, you're
going to fall over, right?
Everyone falls over,
especially as they get older.
And if you break your hip,
that's close to a death sentence.
A lot of people...
Well, 19 people every minute fall over
and break their hip in the United States,
which is a major cause of mortality in-
- Yeah, the mortality
rates after a hip break
just like skyrocket.
- Well, it's equivalent to
having metastatic cancer.
That's how bad it is.
But if you've got muscles
and you're flexible,
you do, say, Pilates in
your older age and stretch,
build up the muscles
particularly around your waist,
then you're much less likely
to break a bone when you fall.
- Building muscle mass
also helps maintain
youthful hormone level?
- Right.
So I had trouble maintaining
testosterone levels
like most men my age.
Now, there are two ways
to go about it generally.
The main one is that your doctor
will give you an injection
of testosterone to apply at home
or a cream that you can
rub on your forearm.
Those are the two ways you can do it.
There are others.
But the other way, which I prefer,
is to naturally boost it by
maintaining large muscles,
exercising my thighs, my butt, my back.
And I've compared the two.
I have tried cream on
my arm for testosterone,
it worked okay, my levels
went up maybe by 20%.
It wasn't great.
I really maxed out my testosterone levels
by doing leg exercise and back exercises.
I'm talking about things like
leg extensions, leg curls,
as well as hip hinge,
which has bending at the
hip and lifting weights.
And I also do deadlifts,
which is standing up,
lifting a really heavy weight
with a straight back.
- There's another way that we know
that exercise is impacting aging.
And we talked about senescent cells
in terms of what iron may be doing
to cause cells to go senescent.
But let's talk about that
as one of the key aging...
what is called the aging hallmarks.
Exercise prevents senescence,
it turns back senescence?
What's exercise doing in
terms of these zombie cells?
- Well, let's start with
what a senescent cell is.
So when the epigenome
becomes too dysregulated
and this ex-differentiation
process happens,
cells can either die,
they can become a cancer/
But what the body tries
to do is to prevent that
by shutting these cells down
and make them more like zombies;
they're alive but they're not dividing,
and they're causing havoc.
- They're excreting all these chemicals
into the bloodstream.
- They are.
It's called the SASP,
the senescence associated
secretory phenotype.
And these proteins cause inflammation,
they also cause cancer.
So the fewer senescent
cells you have in your body,
the better.
And we're starting to find that lifestyle
and supplementation and some drugs
can slow their formation;
remember, keep the iron levels low;
but also we can kill them off.
And there's this study, the
one you're referring to,
which took 34 individuals for
a 12 week exercise program
and looked at the amount
of senescent cells
circulating in the blood immune system,
and it was dramatically lower
in the exercised people,
arguing that you can actually kill off
or reverse that process.
- [Matthew] 12 weeks.
- Just 12 weeks.
- 'Cause these 12 weeks to
destroy some senescent cells
seems like a pretty good deal.
- Yeah, it's one of the best ways
to kill off senescent cells.
- That's the study that
was just out this year
in "Aging Cell," Englund et al.
We will link to that in the show notes.
Let's put a wrap on exercise.
But let's have a few takeaways here.
And there's really,
there's three big ones.
The first is a low level of exercise,
and this is just steps, right?
- Get off your butt.
- [Matthew] Get off your butt and take-
Yeah.
- Standing desk or a
desk with a treadmill.
Walk around the block
after dinner or lunch.
Those are the simple things.
- And you don't have to hit 10,000 steps,
but shoot for-
- Four.
Four's great.
- [David] Yeah.
- Okay. All right.
And then that's the low intensity exercise
that everybody should be
getting throughout the week,
every single day.
You should also get
high intensity exercise.
- For sure.
A few times a week, 10 or 15
minutes, lose your breath.
It can be in the form of HIIT,
high intensity interval training,
or running on a treadmill.
That will get your blood vessels flowing
and your mitochondria amplifying.
- 10 to 15 minutes a day.
Yeah, that's enough.
- 75 minutes a week.
- Yeah, that's what all
the experts recommend.
- Okay. All right.
And then muscle building.
- Yeah, weights, that's just as important.
So maintain that muscle
mass for your hormones,
testosterone particularly
for men and women.
Exercise the big muscles particularly,
don't forget about those.
Don't just work on your
upper arm so you look good.
But it's pretty simple.
You don't need a gym in
your bedroom like I do,
you can do pushups, sit ups,
or just have some weights lying around,
that's sufficient.
- Okay. And all of this, the goal is...
It's not just we want to
look good, we want to...
All of this is aimed toward
the goal of longevity
through putting your
longevity genes into...
Or alerting your genes, your cells,
to a state of adversity.
- Yeah.
The adversity mimetics.
- The adversity mimetics.
I really do like this word.
I think this is going to catch on.
- Yeah, we should trademark that one, Rob.
- Okay. [laughs]
So let's...
Exercise is not the
only adversity mimetic,
there are others.
We're going to talk now
about a few other categories.
We're going to alk
about cold temperatures.
We're going to talk about heat.
But there's a really
exciting one right now,
and it is related, in some ways,
to exercise or the effects...
the genetic effects,
the cellular effects that
we get from exercise,
and it's really fast moving.
The latest studies were only out
in the last couple of years,
and this is hyperbaric oxygen treatment.
- Right. Or HBO2.
Yeah, this is really fascinating
because for a while we
knew that wounds repair
or heal faster when you
give them more oxygen.
- Because why?
- Well, it's not clear.
It could be hormesis,
free radical generation.
It could be that more
oxygen in the tissues
allows them to grow better.
Those are all theories.
But we know that it works.
But then people started putting themselves
in hyperbaric chambers.
The military, certainly the Navy,
have been doing this for a long time
to prevent the bends.
But it's found to be quite therapeutic,
particularly for neurological disorders
but increasingly for aging itself.
- And we should say what a
hyperbaric chamber is, right?
A hyperbaric chamber is a room
or sometimes just a little tube
where the pressure is increased;
and when the pressure is increased,
the amount of oxygen that
you get when you breathe
is increased.
- Right.
You can go up a couple
of atmospheres or more.
And you supplement that with oxygen.
You breathe in a bit more
oxygen or pure oxygen.
And so I recently tried this,
actually, I went out to L.A.
Fortunately, unlike you,
I'm not claustrophobic.
- I'm so...
I couldn't do this.
I can not do this.
- You probably can't.
But it's a glass cylinder,
so you don't feel it.
And I just watched "Schitt's
Creek" for a while,
it was pretty cool especially
when I was high on oxygen.
- You said it was funnier when you...
- It certainly was funnier,
but it might just be because
every time I watch it
it gets funnier.
But it's really relaxing.
I believe I was in
there for about an hour.
And you can meditate in there
or you can fall asleep or watch TV.
It's really a great experience.
But that aside,
what the science says is
that it actually can reverse
an aspect of aging,
which is telomere shortening.
The ends of the chromosomes...
Many of you will have heard of this.
Like the ends of the shoelaces,
the aglets they're called;
if they wear out, it actually
leads to cellular senescence,
the zombie cells.
And this happens over
time as we get older.
And what we've been looking for,
we scientists, for many years,
is a molecule or a treatment
that makes them grow back again
'cause that should help slow down aging
and give us longer life.
And that's what was reported last year
from a group in Israel, who I know well.
I've been over there and
checked out their giant chamber.
- And you actually got
wind of this before...
while they were working on it,
and you went to kind of like peek in
on what they were doing.
- Yeah.
I mean, this is one of the
fortunate things about my job,
is that I get to hear about
things before they're public
and I get a sneak preview.
And I went over there and
sat in their giant chamber,
which looks like the inside of a bus,
and with a mask you put on,
and they showed me their data.
Actually it looked like a
control room from star Trek,
it's really high-tech.
But the data that they showed
me in mice and in humans
was really compelling.
It looked like, at least in the mice,
that those plaques and
tangles in the brain of mice
that were given Alzheimer's went away.
- Do you have the little
miniature hyperbaric chambers
for the mice?
- We're building one 'cause
I'm going to use one in my lab,
but they're not ready yet.
But also what they were finding
was that the humans that were put in there
that had dementia or Parkinson's
were dramatically improved
after a few sessions of this.
And it's become a real
craze throughout the U.S.
A lot of this is happening in L.A.
where a lot of these trends start.
People are reporting remarkable benefits.
Now what we need are more
studies like the one in Israel
to actually measure
things and, if possible,
do a placebo control as well.
- But at least what we have
right now are some studies,
most of them fairly small-scale;
but human studies,
memory improvements,
telomeres, T helper cells.
- Right. They go up as well.
So in cognitive performance,
there were those six elderly patients
suffering from memory loss.
And in 2021, this new study
came out and they all improved.
- And the really cool
thing about this treatment,
even though, look, like,
not everybody has access to a
hyperbaric chamber, obviously,
but it is a pretty easy intervention.
And it's easy to treat people this way,
it's easy to test people in this way.
So if it it works-
- And now we have the clocks.
We have the clocks.
We can test if aging
actually goes backwards.
That would be a good experiment
is to take people who have done 7 or 8,
10 bouts of this
treatment before and after
and see if their biological
age went backwards.
- So it's still early.
It seems like these things are working
across a variety of ways
that we can measure aging
and the problems of aging.
If this is working, why is it working?
- Yeah.
Well, we don't know for sure.
But one of the theories
is that it's working similar to exercise.
So hypoxia, the low oxygen
when you go for a run,
what it's doing is turning
on this HIF-1alpha protein
that I talked about earlier,
and that helps promote health in the body.
The other thing that happens with exercise
is the free radical generation,
that gives you a little
bit of mitohormesis.
It looks very much like hyperoxia.
Hyperbaric chamber treatment
does the very similar thing.
You get a production
of these free radicals
and that stimulates also
a mitohormesis response
that gives you very similar
benefits to low oxygen.
There's one theory that I have,
is that when you come down
from the high levels of oxygen,
it simulates hypoxia like you're running,
as you come down from
high levels to low levels.
- So it's not so much the oxygen,
the explosion of oxygen
that you're getting,
but it's like once you like
temporarily get used to that
then you come off of it-
- It's the differential.
And that fits with the new findings,
which is going up once
and coming down once
is not as good as going up
and down and up and down
within a treatment.
- Before we move away from
hyperbaric oxygen treatment,
I know you're most familiar
with this Israeli study.
Let's talk about the protocol in that one.
- Yeah, they took 30 people
and put them in their large
chamber, the one that I visited.
And they did 60 daily
sessions of 90 minutes,
five of those per week,
and had a look at the
number of senescent cells
in the bloodstream before and
after and telomere length.
And what they found remarkably
was that those aspects
of aging were reversed.
- They saw impacts in senescent cell too?
- They did.
In the immune system,
looking at these immune cells,
you can measure senescence.
You can stain them blue,
which is bright blue when you get older,
and they found that there
was a dramatic reduction
in the number of those
senescent cytotoxic T-cells,
as they're called.
- Okay, so 60 sessions, 90 minutes,
this is not something most
people can do every day
right now.
This is not going to be a common part
of people's longevity
regimens anytime soon.
- Well, there are a number of centers
that are run by doctors in major cities.
It will become more popular,
it's growing rapidly.
But I think it's a great way in the future
for people to mimic exercise.
I wouldn't say don't exercise, right?
But it's an interesting idea
that you can lie down, watch TV,
go to sleep and get your running
by mimicking hypoxia,
but in this case with high
levels of oxygen in your body
for a short period of time.
- It's really cool.
Let's shift now to talking
about cold therapy,
which is another thing
that a lot of people
are experimenting with now,
another thing that there are
centers for all over the place,
but that the research is
still sort of catching up
to the excitement.
So we're sort of on the edge
here of our understanding.
But we do know some things
about what cold does
to the human body
and actually what cold does to organisms
across the spectrum.
- Yeah.
In fact, when we wrote "Lifespan,"
there was almost no data on this.
But now we know actually
that one of the huge benefits
you get from being cold is
the production of brown fat.
So what is brown fat?
Brown, or it's often called
beige fat, is found in babies.
It's typically to allow them to stay warm
because they don't shiver
until they're about one year of age.
And what was discovered
about 10 years ago at Harvard
by Bruce Spiegelman and Ron
Kahn, a couple of my colleagues,
is that adults also have some brown fat,
and they discovered
this with PET scanning,
and they found it mostly
exists on your back
in your shoulder blades.
And when you get cold, it revs up,
you get more of this brown fat.
And this is a good thing because brown fat
is extremely healthy.
It revs up metabolism, it burns white fat.
And we think that there are
these factors, little chemicals,
little proteins that get
secreted out of brown fat
that make the rest of
the body healthy as well.
One of the reasons we know that
is because there's a gene
that makes brown fat,
makes cells turn brown, from
white to beige to brown,
and it's called PRDM16.
And mice that lack this gene,
they don't have brown fat
but they also develop type two diabetes
and cardiovascular disease as a result.
- Cold impacts not just humans,
it impacts all organisms.
We've seen this in model organisms too,
these effects, right?
There's studies in worms,
there's studies in mice.
You've got a couple of favorites, I know.
You like talking about the mice
that got to spoon together.
- Oh yeah.
So that one is a bit of a
disappointment in the field.
We had these dwarf mice
that Mike Bonkowski,
who was working in my lab,
he was the guy that generated
the longest lived mouse,
he called it Yoda.
And it was very long lived
because it had a mutation
in a gene for the growth hormone receptor,
which means they were small and dwarfs.
And these little small
dwarf mice would live
up to three times longer
than normal mouse,
it was quite an amazing thing.
And the field was rejoicing:
"Wow, we've figured
out how to make mammals
live that much longer."
And then it was noticed
that they were shivering,
little cold mice.
And so the researchers thought,
"We'll just give them friends."
- They weren't shivering
because the lab was cold,
they were shivering because?
- They didn't have a companion.
Mice like to live not
solitary, but with other mice.
And so they gave them a buddy,
Each of these dwarves had a buddy.
And then the majority of the
lifespan extension went away.
- When they got their buddy?
- Yeah.
Which is super disappointing, right?
But what it told us was that
a large effect of longevity
was due to them being cold.
- And why is that happening?
When we go back to thinking
about the survival circuit,
what's happening?
- Yeah, well, the trick is
let's go back to the brown fat.
What brown fat has a
lot of is mitochondria.
And within those mitochondria,
they're actually quite different.
They have high levels
of proteins called UCPs,
or uncoupling proteins,
which insert into the
membrane of the mitochondria
and allow those protons that
were built up to leak through;
instead of going through that
pump that makes the energy,
they leak through.
Why is that interesting?
Well, first of all,
that generates heat that helps the animal
and we survive cold,
but also you get fewer
free radicals produced
when you uncouple mitochondria
with these proteins.
And consistent with that,
if you make an animal,
let's say it's a a worm
or a fly or even a mouse,
that has high levels of these UCP genes,
they actually live longer.
So uncoupling and reducing
that free radical load;
and you can do this with
cold therapy, we think;
is beneficial to health.
- And cold therapy, people
call it cryotherapy,
is this like short-term
acute, super-intense...
You've done this before, right?
You did this with Rogan, didn't you?
- Yeah.
Joe said let's go do that
after the show, which I did.
It was pretty chill.
I had to strip down to my underwear
and put gloves on and socks and whatever.
But you get to play music, at least.
I got to choose "Help!" by the Beatles,
which was quite appropriate
because by the end of those three minutes-
- You wanted out.
- Well, the first two minutes, I'm like,
"What's the problem? This isn't cold."
But that last minute,
I really thought I was
going to get hypothermia
and my ears might break off.
- You're chattering and shaking-
- Yeah, you really start to shiver,
which is your body's
way of generating heat
by moving your muscles.
But it was really enjoyable.
I found afterwards I felt stimulated.
I felt lucky to be alive.
And I felt good for a
number of days afterwards,
which is probably because my
mitochondria were revved up
and I was building more brown fat.
The one thing I think
it's worth pausing here
to talk about is:
Why would you do this now?
Why don't you wait till
you're old to do cold therapy?
And what's been found, at least in mice,
is that old mice don't make
brown fat as well as young mice.
So what you want to do is, middle-age,
do these treatments
so that you're ready for old
age when it becomes harder.
- Just like right now we need
to be doing vigorous exercise.
We can't wait until we're
old to do vigorous exercise.
- Yeah, though it's never too late.
We do find that things
work in elderly mice
and elderly people,
but it doesn't work as
well if you start midlife
or even earlier.
- Okay.
And maybe that's like
the cryotherapy stuff
is sort of a can-do vigorous exercise,
but you still have to have that low level
of perceived adversity
just like we have to get lots
and lots of steps in every day.
But we live in these environments,
these temperature controlled environments
where it's like 68 to 72.
That's not how our ancestors lived at all.
- No, we were shivering
probably most of the time
during the ice age for sure,
and our bodies recognize that.
We've got those genes that respond
and they keep us healthy,
as we've talked about.
So there are a number of ways you can...
If you don't have a
cryotherapy center near you,
what do you do?
Well, you can take cold showers.
Some people do that.
I don't, I find that unpleasant.
But you can do that, it's
very cheap to do that.
Or you can do something
that I do actually do,
which is sleep with very
few covers on my bed
and lower down my body temperature.
And that's also been shown to activate
these uncoupling proteins
and build brown fat.
- The opposite side of this is heat,
which is also something
that throughout our evolutionary history
we've had to deal with.
We didn't always live in
temperature controlled buildings.
And we've got some emerging
research on that as well.
- Right, taking your body
out of its comfort zone.
And so-
- All of these things are
about taking your body
out of it's comfort zone, right?
- They are, they are.
And some of them are really enjoyable.
I think sauna bathing,
as it's called in Europe,
is super enjoyable.
And it also is good for your skin,
you get to sweat and get
those pores unclogged.
But this is one of the most
ancient therapies for longevity.
Even before Roman times,
they were bathing in these saunas,
though the Romans would
use fires under the floor.
But this is something that
European still carry on
as a tradition,
particularly in Finland and
other Scandinavian countries,
where these studies are
typically performed on men
for some reason.
But the data that I've looked at,
which we'll put in the show notes,
is that there's absolutely no doubt
that men who partake in sauna
bathing a few times a week,
often at home 'cause they
build this into their houses,
have a dramatic reduction, up to 20%,
in the rate of cardiovascular disease
and mortality caused by heart attacks.
- This isn't happening for the
same reason as cold therapy.
This has nothing to do with brown fat.
There's another thing
that's going on here, right?
- It's different in this case.
What we think goes on in a sauna
is you're activating HSPs.
And these heat shock proteins are helping
to fold proteins correctly
and also stimulate pathways
that are beneficial,
such as building new blood vessels,
making more mitochondria.
And one of the reasons
that I believe it's true
is that in model organisms, take a worm,
if you turn up his shock proteins,
either by giving them a lot of heat
or genetically modifying them,
they also live longer.
- We don't quite know what dosing is right
for sauna baths at this point,
or like how much, how hot the...
Not a ton of research in this area.
- No, but it doesn't seem
like you can overdo it.
I haven't seen any evidence
that it's negative.
And I used to...
Before the pandemic,
I used to go at least once a week
and do multiple bouts of
the heat shock in the sauna
for about 15 minutes
and then jump in an ice
bath which was nearby
for four minutes,
and then cycle that.
- You should probably consult your doctor
before you do that.
- I would, definitely.
And I did.
But, yeah, it can put
some stress on the body,
certainly on the heart.
But, yeah, the idea though
is to shock the body;
heat, cold, heat, cold.
And that way, I think,
you get the maximum benefit
from these adversity mimetics.
- And again, you don't
necessarily need to have access
to a sauna to do this.
I mean, some people can
build them into their home,
some people have them in their gyms,
that's kind of a point of privilege.
Most people have a bath or shower.
- Or hot shower.
I certainly do that.
I like to turn the heat way up.
There are a variety of different saunas.
There's the old fashioned type,
which is the cedar planks,
sitting in there and you just
throw water on hot rocks;
that's traditional.
There are new ones such
as infrared saunas,
and the infrared light
actually penetrate the skin
and is thought, and there's some evidence;
real, believable evidence;
that they also, in the skin layer,
can reverse aspects of aging as well,
and including improve hair growth.
- For some obvious reasons,
there's a lot of questions I
want to ask about hair growth.
We're going to be discussing
hair growth, skin care,
all these like sort of like
cosmetic aspects of aging things
in a future episode.
One of the commonalities
that I'm kind of sensing
in all of these things, right,
you do vigorous exercise
and you get what we term a runner's high,
and you talked about doing the cryotherapy
and you felt like...
What did you say?
Like, blessed to be alive.
I've done sweats and sweat lodges,
and you come out of those things
and it's just like it's
the best drug in the world.
What do you think...
Why are these things so similar?
This happens in the
hyperbaric chamber too.
- Yeah, that's one of
the nice side effects.
That's when you know that you're doing
a good longevity protocol.
'Cause what's happening
at the cellular level
is those three main defense
pathways get turned on;
but at the physiological
level, the neurological level,
you're getting endorphins as well,
and that's when you know
you've actually done the right thing.
- So let's talk about a basic protocol
with the caveat that we always make,
which is everybody's going
to be a little bit different.
But if we're trying to
get sort of like exercise,
cold, heat and hyperbaric,
what's a good way to do that?
We've already talked about
the exercise protocol.
Actually, I don't think
we need to reiterate that.
You need to exercise, get off your butt.
Cold, heat and hyperbaric.
- Yeah.
Well, as I mentioned,
I used to do and I will do again
the cycling of the heat and the cold
about five times during
one day of the week.
This was on a Sunday with my son Benjamin.
But I would say more is better.
There's no evidence that
you can overdo this,
you could even do it every day.
If you don't have access to a gym,
you can always use your house;
you can turn down the temperature
or you can use your shower,
and that will work almost as well
as dunking yourself into a cold bathtub.
Or you could do what Gabby
Reece and Laird Hamilton do,
which is shove us into an ice bath
literally with ice in it.
I think that you don't
need to do that every day.
- Didn't you almost drown?
- I did, but that was different.
That was hyperoxia.
What they do is they make
you do exercise with weights
at the bottom of a pool below your height.
So you're underwater
and you have to jump up with those weights
to get a breath of air.
- And we're not recommending
that at this time.
- No, I think everybody should
go knock on their front door
and do it with them.
No, it's...
But you can get hypoxia from exercise,
it's very similar.
So we've talked about hot and cold.
The hyperbaric is more
of an issue, I think-
- That's a challenge.
- There's not a lot of
these centers around.
And it's expensive, it's hundreds
of dollars per treatment.
But that's in the future,
I think that that...
I wanted to mention that
because it's really interesting
how it's so similar to
exercise and hypoxia
at the molecular level.
But for most people right
now, that's out of reach.
- But that's not the
only thing in the future.
There's a lot of really cool things
coming down the path right now,
that are going to be a fundamental part
of people's lives pretty soon.
We're going to be talking
about a lot of those
in upcoming episodes.
- We are.
And actually I think a lot
of people will be excited
that we can mimic this
adversity with molecules,
with pills, with injections.
And we're going to talk about
that in the next episode.
- In the next episode, yeah.
So in the next episode:
molecules, supplements, longevity,
there's going to be a lot.
- Yeah.
I'm excited about this one
'cause I get questions every day about it.
And I think it's going to be
one of the most downloaded episodes.
- Yeah, I think a lot of people
are going to want to tune in.
- I'm excited to dig in.
- Yeah. Okay, cool.
- Thanks for joining us this episode
on exercise and other
forms of acute stress.
If you're learning from
and enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to it on YouTube,
Apple Podcasts and Spotify.
On Apple,
you have the opportunity to
leave up to a five star review.
If you'd like to support us,
please check out the sponsors
we mentioned at the start.
We've partnered with
companies we truly believe in
and they make this show possible.
We also have a Patreon,
that's patreon.com/davidsinclair,
there you can support the show
at any level that you like.
Thanks again.
And we'll be back next week
to discuss supplements and molecules
like NMN, NR, resveratrol,
and how these impact longevity.